I absolutely love the all about reading curriculum.
It has been a game changer for teaching my homeschoolers how to read.
But it is kind of expensive.
I think the whole thing, the teachers manual,
and everything that comes with it is close to $300.
And if you're a homeschool family living on one income,
that's probably not feasible.
this is something that I do to make this a little bit more reasonable.
For starters, I only have the teachers manual,
work cards, and the readers.
And honestly, you don't need the work cards.
If you just wanna start with something,
start with the teachers guide
and you can make pretty much everything at home.
So the every lesson shows you what the word cards are.
So again, you can make them on index cards,
no big deal. But there are some activities that you probably can't do,
like some of the games and stuff,
because it doesn't show you everything that comes with it.
But the extra activity sheets are listed right here.
And let me show you an activity of how I did this without the activity.
The activity for this lesson was a word flipper,
so I use banana gram tiles to do the same thing.
I made the UFF ending with tiles
and then I said different words and my son changed the beginning tile.
This is the same concept as the word flipper,
except I use things I already had and didn't buy the Activity sheet.
This is just one way to cut cost
to make the all about reading curriculum affordable.